[Musique]
certains magasins il saura choisissent
de vendre à bon marché avec un
multiplicateur de 1 45 à 1 80 au lieu
d'aborder des femmes de ou 2,2 habituels
comme on y arrive t-il et bien cette
enquête de catherine mamet va nous
l'expliquer
monsieur webb qui vous dirigez le
magasin tati c'est une grande surface
quel est votre multiplicateur mon
multiplicateur est très variable nous
avons des articles secondant
multiplicateur 1 40 à 50
nous en avons d'autres en multiplicateur
1,70 nous avons d'autres à 1,80 même
jusqu'à multiplicateur de déserter balou
sur le temps parce que nous faisons un
très gros chiffre d'affaires et nous
achetons de très forte quantité avant la
saison et parce que nous avons le débit
nous avons la consommation nous avons la
vente
les gens viennent plein de partout
scolan 24 collant 6 lip6 maillot de
corps nous avons des pour l'heure à
quatre ans on vient acheter de un peu de
tout chez nous mais qui en août chiffre
d'affaires cette année nous espérons
faire à peu près 300 millions de
nouveaux francs c'est un pull reculer
leur accord j'ai trouvé le même à 30
jours comment vous expliquez tout ça je
vais vous expliquer ces des articles que
nous achetons directement de l'étranger
environ 150 et si froch taxes nous
achetons par cent mille cinq cent mille
pièces s'il est plus cher chez d'autres
commerçants c'est qu'il y a plusieurs
distributions vous avez l'importateur
qui vend grossistes ensuite le grossiste
vent défaut demi grossistes et ensuite
le détaillant donc ce détaillant qui le
ventre entrants des fois il est obligé
d'acheter à 12,15 points pour le mettre
à 25 pour le dire qu'il ya du dakar
médias
il ya des intermédiaires et nous
achetons tous nos articles à 80 consent
à la source c'est-à-dire par très forte
quantité et avant 16 ans pour essayer de
maintenir nos prix très bas
c'est ce qui a fait notre publicité
c'est là qu'un média qui commet quelque
800 automatiquement chacun prend son
taux de marque c'est normal
[Musique]